ti ho fatto anche un regalo guarda
questa è la mia mazza dice una copia del
gioco posso averla discorso
incoraggiante fratello non sei
abbastanza famoso grazie dice perché ti
spacco la mascella ed a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj e oggi il suo nono episodio di
youtubers line che sembra un po il
grande fratello di youtube
devo anche stare attento che che ogni
mese devo pagare l'affitto ma lavora
faiotto no non l'ho sbagliato non ho
sbagliato per 12 ore
mi danno un sacco d'esordio wifi questo
o ragazzi le news e le sto facendo è
25.000 views 26 239 dollari ragazzi sto
mettendo da parte un bel gruzzoletto un
po perché devo pagarmi l'affitto un po
perché voglio comprarmi un computer
nuovo che mi fa veramente cagare come
stai
vengo a giocare latte proporne oggi a
devo fare video degli toglierci dalle
pene su entrambi i monitor che è
successo ho comprato niente questo è
successo ai soldi dell'affitto giusto
giusto rifacciamo tutto ragazzi tutto
quanto rifaccio mouse nuovo camera a 169
dollari perfetto grandissimo soprattutto
soprattutto vai vai perfetto oggi chi
cazzo è questa voglio invitarvi ad un
party stasera chi è questa piccole tette
sì ma io sono quasi fidanzato non puoi
invitarmi alla festa ragazzi programma a
fare il nuovo video adesso che c'è un
nuovo tutta nuova attrezzatura full hd
baso fa e video full hd ragazzi tanta
roba
e adesso sì che facciamo un sacco di
virus mi chiami ghiaccio il mic nuovo
bella quasi centomila viuzza video cioè
mare cavani che stiamo parlando se
tantissimo ma mica da da un mondo ambito
all'altro suo passato più di pato
diventato è va bene quanti punti con i
nuovi con la nuova attrezzatura sono un
fenomeno puoi chattare ma chi sei se un
maschio marlevar che ha guadagnato music
altro la musica nell'altro ave
addirittura è diventato troppo figo sto
gioco da quando ho iniziato a carburare
quei video c'è veramente stupendo ok
ragazzi ma in tutto questo poi non ho
più cagato la mia tipa è veri ciao
tesoro come stai invita a casa che
facciamo sesso
lei è un po di roba ciao tesoro ciao fa
vj ma perché mi devi pj mi chiamo
lorenzo porca [ __ ] domani è il mio
compleanno
questo e 6 aprile domani il mio
compleanno mi hai portato la torta no va
bene allora bene la porta mi fuori
usciamo vi ho fatto anche un regalo
guarda questa è la mia mazza sempre i
fiori le d'aria mente cioè una serra in
casa abbracciano a giocare ai
videogiochi ma ti sei innamorata dei
miei videogiochi di me ma pazzia non
importa grazie per essere stato con me
però devo fare video poi andare a
cercarsi un altro tipo o una tipa in
casa ma io faccio i video per voi
philosophical comment 9 di lampadine
aiutato la pizza continua girarmi per la
stanza brutta stronza guarda che staff
ai video va a casa tua
ma cosa fa perché c'è una tipa nel video
vediamo scandalo succedesse mai a
soldato del genere in un video e un vero
2 perfetto mai stato un gran video che
temario 3 quasi centomila views lega
invito a un evento che già fa vj siamo
contenti di invitarti la presentazione
del videogioco wilde balon stavo a
invitarmi a vedere i filmati 6 ma che si
dicono chi ti conosce vai via deficiente
o una tipa io non possono mica andare
con tutte che sono rocco siffredi a
domandare alla presentazione ragazzi
perfetto come vi presento visto che
rilasciano un videogioco con la canotta
vai zio fi spacca come sempre il
cappello da russo medio chissenefrega fi
che facciamo che andiamo a presentarci
che mi regalano pure white balon
resistance è un gioco per xbox che non
ci prova ciao zio dice una copia del
gioco posso averla discorso
incoraggiante fratello immaginate se
all'e3 di los angeles quando presentano
i videogiochi il tipo che sta sul palco
che parla davanti a milioni di persone
fatica non ho parole mi dai una coppia
di sta roba per cortesia bravo
complimenti il discorso soddisfacente
zio mi ha dato una coppia di stack a
khatami ha solo invitato per dirmi cosa
che non mi interessa non mi ha dato una
copia di sta stronzata va bene 43 mila
iscritti potrò farmela la foto non sei
abbastanza famoso grazie dice perché ti
spacco la mascella e va bene non fa
niente
che è successo fuori j thank you prego
perché mi hanno ringraziato che sono
andato a vedere le cose ma figurati
gioco di merda final premier
posso comprare il software di editing
gioco dell'anno per questo è il blu il
blues e il blu jedi in realtà ragazzi si
chiama proietti però va bene anche blu
jedi per carità di dio airi palestro
computer tra il 2000 e 2000 dormire con
una madonna to ripara mentre io dormo
ripara ripara la zia non appena riparato
madonna la massey assestate quella ma
chi l'ha invitata quella lira perché
vieni a casa mia collo fiori first
impressions fi
le prime impressioni sul collo fiori dai
facciamo 360 hanno scopre trick shot
cross ma vi do del genere fanno di
quelle music è minka deve crollare tutta
youtube e tuta google a rischio il
copyright così perché questa roba qua
presa il signor c'è di strano
l'altro è bellissimo perché veramente
call of duty ha fatto bene magari sta
roba qua che che ho rubato il video di
un altro magari la taglio in montaggio
non lo so ma vuol dire che mi danno per
forza lo strike ovvero si incazzano di
brut su pirlo strech sono morto manca
solo strike e avrà sto video siccome non
puoi fare due cose contemporaneamente
quindi mentre carica al lido non puoi
fare un altro video perché sei scemo
vai a lavorare fa qualcosa vi diamo
ragazzi comprare le console però non ho
capito quali mi tengo facciamo così mi
tengo i soldi da parte
sei un dito in culo mamma mia
no è copyright risolvi 360 questo video
warning paga se togli titoli più tolgono
il copyright ma quando ha perso 170
dollari perfetto la prossima volta che
prova ad avere un'idea così geniale
impedì temi di farlo
ok ci guardavi gli iscritti non ci credo
50 mila iscritti quando raggiunto 50mila
iscritti erano youtube e conosciuto la
mia stanza stava diventando troppo
piccola per me e avevo bisogno di
qualcosa di più grosso un posto più
grosso dove fare i video avevo bisogno
del mio personale appartamento quindi ti
trasferisci ha detto staccata però non
si trasferisce in scena o rega sono
diventato
grosso come youtuber scrivetevi al
canale di scott e fatemi capire il
perché io dovrei cambiare appartamento
solo perché ho 50 mila iscritti che sono
gli iscritti quanto escono quella
guardate gli iscritti quota 354 ha fatto
100 mila vi uso il video di cod c'è ma
di cosa stiamo parlando questo mi da 132
dollari se faccio un video su cosa vuoi
che lo faccia al suo video del melò per
l'amico soft boxe quindi devo comprare
un xbox devo comprare vuoi chattare no
donna non tempo devo comprare l'xbox e
tu mi danno sempre videogiochi di
console che non so perché cento ci si si
non ci siamo mai posso comprare subito
comprano aspetta quale delle due che ha
speso due una costa 500 dollari e mi sa
che non ma posso permettere l'altra se
credo che sia la z box non 360 quella
normale la z box quella normale di
missili cinesi e la città porzione
normale grazie a dio bye bye bye bye che
ma arriva dai mari va a casa ma arriva a
casa ragazzi ciò la z box però prima
devo andare assolutamente a dormire
perché sennò muoio
no no no che vendi ma sei scemo che
facciamo che poi facciamo gameplay new
che mi dico ci siamo ragazzi sto per
fare il video sulla z box wire ruby
formento 8 aprile ok 20 aprile ci siamo
qua john white room dai e facciamo dai e
ci posso credere ragazzi spolli chat e
fino a che non vi si scassa lato stato
no perchè questo qua invito da una donna
e non puoi non sto dice ma io c'ho la
scheda di acquisizione come faccio a
registrare guardate il cazzato gioco
proprio di merda stai calmo però è stato
citato non è un gioco forum stai
tranquilla vediamo se me li danno 631
dollari verso video ragazzi si pone
lizzate v che non rompete la tastiera
sta caricando
sì comunque ragazzi io vorrei capire ma
come faccio ad avere una linea più
veloce non posso chiama tipo fastweb e
di raul varchi adryan thank you for this
colmi prego mi ha dato un sacco di soldi
non ci credo mai anzi possiamo andare a
[ __ ] adesso hanno già avere sementa
jowga all'xbox frutta deficiente o
incredibile quindi ragazzi spero che
video vi sono scemo ha lanciato il
telecomando subito un fa male giocare i
giochi sugli youtubers ci vediamo
assorbito lega continuano nel prossimo
ovunque e la tipa non me la cavo più
perché chi fa i video non può avere
relazioni tranne che con i suoi fan
beh ragazzi